lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
practicar un poquito acerca de cómo se
crea el dinero en las economías que
están basadas en el mercado después
podemos platicar un poquito más acerca
de qué es el dinero y quizás después nos
podamos meter más en detalles técnicos y
en vídeos futuros creo que el hecho ya
hice algunos vídeos con detalles
técnicos pero bueno en casi todas las
economías que están basadas en un
mercado hay un banco central ese banco
central es pues uno de los actores
principales de la economía hacen muchas
cosas como labores reguladoras pero su
labor principal es tener el derecho de
imprimir dinero y poner ese dinero en
circulación entonces ahorita pues te voy
a contar un poquito del banco de méxico
que es un banco central déjalo como con
otro color entonces el banco central y
el banco central en algunos países pues
es parte de el gobierno en otros como en
méxico el banco central es medianamente
independiente podemos decir que es como
pseudo independiente porque aunque el
artículo 28 lo declara como una
institución independiente realmente el
gobierno está muy involucrado con él por
ejemplo a su junta de gobierno la elige
parcialmente el presidente y luego esto
tiene que ser ratificado por él
tiene que rendirle cuentas al congreso
de la unión y su junta de gobierno puede
ser sujeta a juicio político pero bueno
cuando el banco central decide imprimir
dinero literalmente puede crearlo es
decir puede ya sea imprimir dinero
físico o puede crearlo electrónicamente
que es básicamente es lo mismo entonces
supongamos que tenemos un banco central
y que imprime tres billetes digamos tres
billetes de veinte pesos no por decir
algo ahorita nos vamos a enfocar nada
más en el dinero físico porque pues es
más fácil dejar fijar las ideas así y
supongamos que tenemos tres billetes de
20 pesos ahora como ya hacemos para
meter eso en circulación como lo metemos
a la economía o sea no podemos nada más
subir a un helicóptero y aventar lo
entonces en algunas circunstancias puede
ser que el banco le preste esto
directamente a algún banco como un
préstamo de emergencia tienen que ser
bancos especiales y tienen que estar
asociados con el banco de méxico pero la
forma típica en la cual esto entra en
circulación es que el banco utiliza este
dinero para comprar bueno estas reservas
como quiera llamarle pero las utiliza
para ir al mercado abierto al mercado
libre y compra valores usualmente son
valores gubernamentales
para que sean muy seguros entonces toman
este dinero y lo meten al sistema lo
meten en circulación a cambio están
obteniendo valores gubernamentales del
mercado abierto entonces aquí vienen
algunos algunos valores déjalos pongo
aquí le pongo valores valores tal vez
debería de ponerle bonos o algo así pero
bueno una vez que hacen eso cualquier
persona bueno las personas que que eran
los dueños de estos valores
ahora tienen estos billetes ellos pues
tienen dos opciones verdad podrían
depositar los en el banco o bien podrían
gastarlo pero incluso si los gastan pues
eso va a llegar a otra persona y en
algún momento ese billete va a
depositarse en un banco entonces al
comprar estos valores alguien va a hacer
que estos billetes de pesos caigan en un
banco privado déjame dibujar eso de allí
entonces por acá por acá tenemos un
banco privado y entonces ahora tiene
estos tres billetes estos tres billetes
de 20 pesos entonces ahora tiene algunas
reservas adicionales
aquí no acaba la historia este dinero de
aquí ahora puede ser prestado y esto es
súper importante verdad porque esto es
típico en casi todas las economías o más
bien todas las economías de mercado que
tengan un sistema de préstamo de reserva
fraccionaria sistema de préstamo de
reserva fraccionaria aquí es donde
empiezan a pasar cosas raras verdad
porque el pp a la persona le estás
diciendo a la persona que acaba de
depositar que en cualquier momento puede
ir al banco y puedes exigir su dinero o
sea que su dinero está a la vista el
banco le dice tú tranquilo yo tengo todo
bajo control y puedes pedir todo tu
dinero cuando quieras sin embargo la
realidad es que el banco tiene permitido
tener sólo una fracción en reservas y
prestar lo demás puede prestar lo demás
y bueno para que el sistema no sea
también estable el banco central se
tiene que inventar algo así como un
seguro del cual después hablaremos por
el momento nada más no voy a enfocar en
cómo se crea el dinero en este sistema
de reserva fraccionaria entonces este
banco de acá dice voy a guardar tantito
de reservas en caso de que venga algunos
de mis clientes la probabilidad de que
vengan todos es súper baja entonces pues
yo creo que nada más voy a guardar un
poquito el resto del dinero el que no
esté
reservas lo voy a prestar aunque prometí
que todo el dinero va a estar disponible
lo voy a prestar se lo presto a algunos
inversionistas que se vean que tienen
proyectos pues con un riesgo decente
verdad y a esos inversionistas no se les
voy a abrir una cuenta de cheques o lo
que sea
ellos lo gastan pueden construir una
fábrica o comprar un coche lo que sea
entonces ese dinero se lo dan a alguien
más esas nuevas personas ahora tienen
dinero y lo van a depositar en un banco
entonces este dinero lo que va a acabar
pasando es que va a acabar en algún
banco puede ser el mismo banco pero
déjame dibujar otro banco para que
dibujo quede más fácil entonces va a
acabar en otro banco ahí tenemos dos
billetes ahora este banco también tiene
permitido nada más tener tantito en
reservas por simplicidad vamos a pensar
digo en casi todos los sistemas
bancarios en las economías modernas se
permite tener como el 10 por ciento en
reservas y el resto se puede prestar
aquí estamos pensando en una reserva un
poco más grande que básicamente es para
que el dibujo nos quede más bonito y sea
fácil de dibujar entonces supongamos que
este banco decide tener la mitad en
reservas entonces éste lo guarda y este
de acá lo puede prestar
no presta se lo da a alguien que lo
guarde en el banco o bien pues se lo
paga a alguien lo gasta y ese alguien lo
mete del banco
otra vez podemos pensar que
eventualmente llega a un banco verdad y
vamos a poner un tercer barco déjame
poner el banco amarillo por acá ahí está
un banco más ahí tenemos el billete y
ahora esto está interesante déjame
ponerlo en color verde después voy a
hacer un poco más de las matemáticas de
cuánto dinero se crea es un problema
interesante que tiene que ver con una
suma de una serie infinita que está muy
entretenido si te emociona mucho puedes
buscarlo en este mismo momento pero
bueno ahorita la idea básica es que
aunque el banco central imprimió tres
billetes de 20 pesos que en total serían
que 60 pesos de todas formas hay más
dinero en el sistema mira este cuate de
acá cree que tiene 60 pesos
este otro cree que son 40 y ese otro 20
y entonces en total en este ejemplo
tenemos que un dos tres cuatro cinco
seis por veinte serían 120 pesos déjame
escribir por aquí que aquí tenemos 120
pesos en el sistema 120 ahora podrías
preguntarte si esto realmente es dinero
porque este cuate tiene dos billetes que
no está usando y si los quisiera
tendrá que retirarlos y no se podría
hacer todo esto pero en esta parte es
súper importante que tengamos cuentas de
cheques estoy suponiendo que todo esto
son cuentas de cheques a la vista
entonces la razón por la cual este cuate
no retira su dinero y se preocupa al
respecto es que de todas formas puede
utilizar ese dinero como forma de pago
por ejemplo digamos que este es todo el
dinero que tiene el cuate y de repente
le da hambre que quiere así muchísimo
comprar una manzana y que esa manzana
cuesta 20 peluchín salió muy cara pero
bueno mira es una manzana muy bonita
claramente cuesta 20 pesos
bueno este cuate no necesita sacar todo
su dinero del banco porque puede
escribir un cheque entonces ahorita
tiene derecho a tus 60 pesos verdad
entonces puede escribir un cheque por 20
pesos 20 pesos se lo escribe al frutero
al cuate del mercado le dan la manzana l
del cheque y entonces ahora el vendedor
de manzanas tiene derecho a reclamar 20
pesos de acá a lo mejor ahora el
vendedor escribe un cheque pero el
chiste es que el billete nunca salió del
sistema bancario gracias a los cheques
pues se pueden hacer este tipo de
intercambios y se puede utilizar el
dinero que en teoría está prestado como
moneda entonces de todas formas podemos
utilizar ese dinero a través de cheques
ya sea pensando los cheques como moneda
por sí mismos o nada más como
transferencias de derecho para obtener
ese dinero en el banco bueno la gran
razón por la cual estoy haciendo todos
estos dibujos es que quiero mostrarte
que la cantidad de dinero en circulación
pues no está totalmente en el control
del banco central o sea ellos pueden
decidir imprimir un poco más de dinero
comprar valores poner el dinero en
circulación o sacar dinero de
circulación verdad a lo mejor pueden
venderlas los valores y cuando venden
los valores a lo mejor este cuate le da
el dinero al banco central y el banco
central pues ya puede eliminarlo pero
tenemos todo este efecto de acá si
tenemos más préstamo verdad si los
bancos están muy seguros de sí mismos
entonces va a suceder más de esto de
aquí y entonces vamos a tener un efecto
multiplicador
más grande por otro lado si los bancos
no están tan seguros van a prestar menos
y vas a ver que esto de aquí se contrae